The Avengers weren't my first family.
At some point we all have to choose.
Between what the world wants you to be.
And who you are.
Welcome back, everyone it's Charlie!
This is going to be my new Marvel phase 4 Avengers
video Marvel does revealed a bunch of details
about what's going on with their next Avengers
roster in the next generation, so to speak
of Avengers.
So if you're new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
will do a new Amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be subscriber and let me
know who you want to be on that next Avengers
roster in Avengers 5 so just breaking everything
down starting with number 5 recently Marvel
did a big phase 4 interview and revealed
some key details about what's going on with
the characters in Marvel phase 4 with the
legacy Avengers after vendors and game in
the characters that will be part of the next
Avengers movie in Avengers 5 when they
eventually get around to making that movie
there were actually only a couple Avengers
actors who said they were done for the most
part with Marvel movies after Avengers endgame
they killed two and retired quote of quote
the third one Ironman black widow died confirmed
sacrificing themselves black widow to get
the soul stone on for mere and Ironman snapping
the nano infinity gauntlet Marvel did confirm
that they are both dead actually dead after
the end of Avengers endgame in 2023, but the
big thing here is all about what's happening
during the black widow movie, so Kevin Feige
and Marvel said the black widow movie would
start their new Marvel phase 4 story in
a much bigger way than they did during Spider-Man
far from home because technically that's a
Marvel phase 4 movie, but it's really more
of an epilogue for Marvel phase 3 is more
of a teaser for Marvel phase 4 like that
little attack at the end scene, we can't wait
to show you what comes next the black widow
movie is really the first Marvel phase 4 movie,
so when they announced that the plot was actually
supposed to be up prequel set after the events
of Captain America Civil War.
But before Avengers infinity war, everyone
was confused about how the movie was going
to start a new Marvel phase 4 infinity saga
style overarching story that they just tease
through all the Marvel phase 4 movies like,
what is the next big event that they're building
up to that they'll start teasing during the
black widow movie.
So this interview that they just did the posted
clears up a lot of those details the black
widow movie actually makes a lot more sense
now.
Number four.
The director the black widow movie Kate shortly
and said that the movie is origin story, just
not the origin story for the character you
expected.
Most people expecting a Natasha black widow
origin story, because we haven't really gotten
that they've only referenced it in previous
movies.
This was her full quote from that she said
Kevin Feige realize that the audience would
expect in origin story, so of course we went
in the opposite direction and we didn't know
how great Florence Pugh would be, we knew
she would be great, but we didn't know how
great scarlet is so gracious like oh I'm handing
her the baton's was going to propel another
female storyline what that means them going
in the opposite direction quote of quote as
you probably guessed, is that the black widow
movie is in origin story for how Yelena Belova
played by Florence Pugh becomes the new black
widow of the MCU heading into Marvel phase
for maybe that's not a big surprise for a
lot of use of you probably guessed that she
would probably become the next black widow
heading into Marvel phase 4.
There were some people I think that were hoping
there would be some big scroll twist in Natasha
would come back and revealed that she was
really alive in present day.
This destroys a lot of fan theories about
the Avengers timeline through endgame and
confirms a bunch of other theories about the
future of the MCU so obvious he first big
thing in Natasha black widow is still confirmed
dead in present day after the end of Avengers
endgame in the year 2023 that is officially
right now the present day of the MCU the black
widow movie will probably have some other
flashbacks referencing Natasha when she was
even younger, but mostly it takes place right
after Captain America Civil War there a lot
of people asking why the whole couldn't bring
Natasha back with the infinity gauntlet snap
or why she couldn't come back after Captain
America returned the soul stone to for mere
the Russo's and the writers of Avengers endgame
basically said that bringing her back would
completely undercut the dramatic weight of
her sacrifice, so no dice.
There was no way she was going to come back
to life at the end of that movie.
Also, Scarlett Johansson revealed that she
was the reason why there was no funeral scene
for black widow.
She said that Natasha wouldn't want a funeral
because most of them didn't even really know
her.
This kind of the theme of the black widow
trailer you don't really know my past you
know a lot of things about me but you don't
know the real me, number three also in that
interview Scarlett Johansson said that she
was metaphorically passing the baton to Florence
pews Yelena Belova black widow which means
passing the mantle it also means Yelena Belova
survives the end of the black widow movie
in the present day after the events of Avengers
endgame there a lot of theories about what
happens to her character, but where was Yelena
Belova during Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame.
That's a big question mark that will also
probably be explained during the end of the
black widow movie.
So this is where I think that thunderbolt
Ross comes in.
He seems like he's in some important parts
of the movie in a very Nick fury type of role.
So we know Yelena Belova gets her origin stories
the new black widow during the movie her back
story is actually very similar to Natasha's
they were effectively sisters growing up together
inside the red room program like they talk
about being a family in the black widow trailer
read guardian was kind of their surrogate
father the Melina black widow was kind of
their surrogate mother, so Yelena Belova has
that same red on her ledger Backstory problem
that Natasha had she committed a lot of war
crimes while she was one of the black widows
inside the red room program when they were
all still active during Avengers endgame right
before she sacrifices herself Natasha black
widow has this big speech about how Hawkeye
saw past all that and gave her a chance to
do something better with her life.
That's probably a reference to Budapest, which
hopefully they'll pay off during the black
widow movie, but early theory here this a
similar moment for Yelena Belova at the end
of the black widow movie were thunderbolt
Ross offers her a chance to clear the red
on her ledger works for me or you can rot
in prison for all the war crimes you committed
while she was a black widow you can stay here
in the raft for the rest of your natural life
or you can work for me and earn your freedom.
So number two.
Here's where we get to the new Avengers roster
Avengers 5 and thunderbolts because that's
going to be such a long time before Avengers
5 happens the earliest based on this movie
schedule and all the subsequent delays is
like 2023 2024 is going to be a long ass time
before we see that movie, so it's more likely
that they want Florence Pugh to come back
before that happens in another project, implying
that something with the thunderbolts will
probably be happening sooner and possibly
on Disney plus maybe a movie.
They haven't really said what their plans
are for the thunderbolts team in the MCU yet
there slowly setting up the thunderbolts inside
the MCU starting with falcon winter soldier.
They have all these villains are former villains
that are still alive after vendors and game
and still rotting in prison on the raft which
is kind of thunderbolt Ross is base of operations
Baron's email is just good to be one of the
first ones inside falcon winter soldier.
He's a prime candidate and he's led thunderbolt
teams in the past Marvels kind of implied
that temporarily after vendors and game the
Avengers team is kind of on hiatus with all
the surviving Avengers team members off doing
their own things.
For the next couple of years like Spider-Man
has way bigger problems.
Short-term to deal with than joining another
Avengers roster, but there a lot of other
people out there a lot of other villains that
will want to take advantage of the Avengers
not being active.
So thunderbolt Ross is sort of the person
that would be called the step in by the world
Security Council tasked with holding the peace
in the world.
He's already creating a new Captain America
with the US agent character in falcon winter
soldier by restarting the weapons plus program
which is just a version of the super soldier
program will see all that play out during
the falcon winter soldier series.
So that just the beginning of that.
So you already have two members to could join
a thunderbolts roster.
You can take your pick from any of the other
Marvel villains that are still around.
They haven't killed off yet you have the ghost
you have read hold thunderbolt Ross you have
Yelena Belova black widow now confirmed there
still the abomination in the leader who are
chilling out on the raft in prison right now.
They even have Justin hammer to make all their
weapons for them.
Number one, though.
As for the next Avengers roster in Avengers
5, even though short-term it seems like
Yelena Belova black widow will be doing more
thunderbolts type stuff with thunderbolt Ross.
When Scarlett Johansson says she's passing
the baton to her character metaphorically
that implies she's also going to replace Natasha
on the next Avengers roster along with people
like falcon who are eventually going to take
the mantle Captain America.
There bunch of other more powerful characters
that will be joining that next Avengers team
in Avengers 5 like Black Panther is probably
the best example, we get the idea Marvel phase
4 is swerving on some of the origin stories
and doing origin stories for some of the people
who we become new Avengers.
Eventually, the reason doing that a little
bit during the eternal's movie, they will
all be Avengers.
There's way too many characters in that movie,
but Kevin Feige implied.
The kit Harringtons black night would crossover
in future Avengers movies bigger team up down
the road that movies coming out in February,
so hopefully will either get the full trailer
later this summer or the just way to release
it till November when they drop the black
widow movie, but let me know in the comments
if Yelena Belova is the next official black
widow in the MCU which next project you want
to see her appearing during Marvel phase 4
either Disney plus series or Marvel phase
4 movie Marvel's been kind of quiet lately
but they'll be a lot more big Marvel news
this summer because of all the comic con stuff
is happening really soon.
So will do as many videos for everything is
possible leave all your requests in the comments
below everyone click here for my new guarding
to the galaxy 3 Easter eggs video and click
here for that.
Deleted scene of Michael Keaton's Batman from
crisis on infinite earths.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe. I'll see you guys tonight!